ich war mal wieder in den youtube trends
unterwegs und hab dann zu videos gesehen
wie beispielsweise rgb reingeschaut
gesetzbuch summerjam erster alle keine
ahnung was das für einen deutsch ist der
ausländische vater striche johannes
jonas wer wird kann apostroph
fragezeichen planeten kenne ex der
[ __ ] aber ein video hat alles wieder
rausgerissen abhol red bull official
video ja meine damen und herren ab red
hat sich mal wieder zurückgemeldet auf
der plattform youtube nämlich mit einem
neuen zorn
wir können uns ja noch alle an seiner
bisherigen songs erinnern
[Musik]
das ist qualitativ hochwertige musik
dann passierte ja das was wir alle
mitbekommen haben absatzkanal ist in die
irrelevanz abgesunken er hat eine
anzeige bekommen wegen der im
bombenkrieg saß in untersuchungshaft
weil er den gerichtstermin verschlafen
hat es gab ganz ganz viele dinge die in
seinem leben vorgefallen sind doch nun
hat sich das youtube sternchen
schlechthin zurückgemeldet mit einem
neuen song der von heißt below
ich bin gespannt wenn man zwei
buchstaben an den track namen ändern
würde hieße der song billig aber so
einen namen für einen treckern höchstens
katja demnächst verwenden bevor wir uns
den song geh zu gemüte führen würde ich
sagen schauen wir mal wieder die
kommentare rein da steht oha viermal
soviel likes wie dislike ziel erreicht
wer die slide ist um ihren mann einfach
von lat ist schokolade geklaut
also die ersten 3 kommentare davon sind
zwei wirklich positiv und einer sagt es
sei geklaut bevor wir uns dieses lied
ist schokolade mal genauer anschauen und
schauen ob das wirklich geklautes müssen
wir erstmal bildung gehört haben aber
jetzt schauen wir erstmal noch ein paar
weitere kommentare annähen nicht zu
meinen geschmack ich finde range rover
ist ein einziger guter song achte nicht
auf diese negativen kommentare die
wollen nicht nur provozieren oder nerven
weil sie eifersüchtig sind yalla habibi
die stimme voll sowie rafft kamera platz
eins respekt ab okamura feierlich ich
fande photoshop und es ist ziemlich
unnötig aber man merkt mega dass du dich
verbessert hast willst du grad kamera
sein ge ist ihr auch gelungen einfach
nur geil
also man muss wirklich sagen die
kommentare sind sehr unterschiedlich es
gibt sehr viele leute tatsächlich die
sagen dass das lied echt mega geil sei
und er sich mega verbessert hat es gibt
allerdings auch leute die sagen ist sei
nur geklaut von rough kamera oder das
komplette lied sei geklaut von diesem
schokolade aber wir bilden uns natürlich
wieder selbst gemeinden wie immer
freunde ich habe nichts persönlich gegen
abo rettig hat er sogar früher ein
bisschen was mit ihm zu tun jetzt
irgendwie in den letzten jahren
allerdings nicht mehr ich habe auf jeden
fall überhaupt rein gar nichts gegen ihn
persönlich ich finde es wirklich netter
kerl muss ich ganz ehrlich gesagt zu
geben und wir gehen wieder völlig
unvoreingenommen dieses lied jetzt rein
[Musik]
ich kann direkt zu beginn sagen der beat
hört sich mega geil an
was ich ehrlich gesagt sorry dass ich
die ganze zeit unterbrechen aber es ist
halt meine reaktion auf den sommer also
wenn ihr den song komplett anhören wollt
findet ihr denn noch mal in der infobox
verlinkt was ich einfach nicht verstehe
und was mir hier auch wieder auffällt
ist er steht jetzt gerade hier in einem
parkhaus wenn man allerdings mal ein
bisschen zurückspulen sehen wir steht er
hier auf einem sportplatz dann merkt bei
allen kassen musikvideos aus amerika von
irgendwelchen hip hoppern von keine
ahnung was von trade von was ich wem
oder so das sind immer relativ ähnliche
locations die irgendwie was miteinander
zu tun haben allerdings hat ein parkhaus
nichts zu tun mit dem fantreffen auf dem
fußballplatz
[Musik]
wieso steigt er aus seinem mercedes
range rover mansory ja dass man meinen
könnte ihn abo kameraden also ich würde
der komplette anfang des liedes bilder
von apo-med weil mehr habe ich noch
nicht gehört
hört sich genauso an wie primo von rough
kamera ich denke jeder hat irgendwie
primo schon mal ab und angehört weil es
einfach voll lang in den deutschen
charts war so das war quasi jetzt timo
von rough kamera letzten mal bei abu
raed ideen anfang an und zwar gut
[Musik]
wann hören auf es ist ein bisschen wie
gar nichts an oder als es sagt nichts
oder gar nichts ich weiß nicht ob das
aus neuss die fafga morath man merkt
dass sich ab oder sehr sehr krass
inspiriert hat ich will nicht sagen dass
es geklaut ist oder kopiert weil den
style haben ja sehr viele gerade also
noch auf kamera und so dieser fußballer
vergleich es gibt immer diese fußballer
vergleiche entweder mit xabi alonso oder
david alaba immer gleichen alle sich mit
fußballern
papa fährt ranger der jungunternehmer
achte apo rot färbten range rover also
irgendwie verstehe ich das nicht so ganz
das ist das ja ich spiele euch jetzt mal
ein paar sekunden von apo med
das ist so geht das los und jetzt wenn
wir mal ein bisschen vorspulen und quasi
der richtigere frage kommen kommt zwar
wieso
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal eben kurz
ganz kurz von bones im cfk moralisches
und maxwell hier das ja so
um kohle
jetzt zeige ich eben sagt nix von rough
kamera
und sagt ich war und jetzt zeige ich
euch noch ganz kurz primo von rough
kamera
ich habe gerne gespielt
das waren jetzt drei verschiedene lieder
in denen allen immer raff kamera drin
war einmal sagt nix raff kamera alleine
dann halt kontrollieren was denkt jeder
kennt was auch schon fast jahre alt ist
dann halt primor und dann apa red man
merkt sehr sehr krass dass er ist ja
sehr sehr stark daran orientiert ich
sehe jetzt nicht so ernst wie es einige
in den kommentaren geschrieben haben
also für mich ist es jetzt nicht so dass
er die kopiert aber man merkt halt sehr
krass dass er da wirklich die die wieder
gesehen hat und sich gedacht hat okay so
was muss ich irgendwie als youtuber
jetzt auch mal machen und schauen wie es
auf youtube funktioniert so das ist
genau exakt gleich einfach finde ich ok
sympathische spielt da gerade glaub ich
fortnight oder irgendwie so und frisst
dabei sein heber also indem sie es uns
also selbst ein bisschen auf dem haben
wären die ganzen anderen so raff camora
180 geben keine ahnung wer alles die rap
ist darüber auf wie sie sogar ihre
bildschirm und er sagt so erlebt im
bilde
also er kopiert so ein bisschen den
style beziehungsweise orientiert sich
daran aber macht das ganze so ein
bisschen noch lächerlich dadurch dass er
sagt dass er so jubelte büro ist aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen meine damen
und herren dieser song here von apo-med
ich weiß nicht ob wir haben es dann
gleich nochmal ein bisschen weiter an
und was macht er damit der scheiß melone
apa red du bekommst von mir wirklich den
ring
doch für diesen track dicker der ist
megageil geworden ohne spaß ich feiere
das mega natürlich orientiert du dich
sehr sehr krass an anderen deutschen
künstlern und so aber jetzt ist es ist
geil es ist jetzt nicht so krass wie
case der einfach komplettes respektvoll
von gashi einfach eins zu eins übersetzt
hat und bei sich hochgeladen hat und
sogar die gleichen beat genommen und
komplett kopiert aber man merkt du
machst dir gedanken man merkt diese
kleine auszeit sage ich mal hat ihr gut
getan
liga ab und feierte ein content immer
noch nicht aber der track ist mega gut
ich bin
die ga warum fünf jahre die eier die auf
dem boden sind angewiesen auf der
anderen seite muss man natürlich sagen
dass das komplette web seinem bisherigen
content überhaupt nicht irgendwie
übereinstimmt in alten liedern von ihm
also ich weiß ja dass musik nennen kann
aber hat er auch gesagt sie steigt aus
den betten sei ein nagelneuer r8 und
keine ahnung was und dann hier sieht an
und so und jetzt hier tut er so als wäre
der übelste lappen verdient nichts und
trainiert in seinem zimmer und raucht
shisha in seinem zimmer und lebt wie ein
büro und kaufte sich lidl irgendwelche
jahr produkte ein
[Musik]
aber man muss aber auch mal sagen dass
die videoproduktion also die
systematische sache hier überhaupt nicht
geil es versteht mich nicht falsch das
ist gut für einen youtuber song das wäre
wenn es ein ganz normaler song wäre wäre
es gut produziert und alles allerdings
ist der song wirklich hier diesmal und
nicht hier aber das video ist halt immer
noch hier also wenn er jetzt noch
irgendwie nicht einmal 10.000 euro mehr
für das video aus gegeben hätte wäre das
ganze beides hier und werden meinen
augen
ist der song des jahres ich würde
allerdings sagen wir jetzt auch genug
auf den von ihr reagiert als wenn man
die den den refrain gehört wir haben die
hoch gehört die cetera pp hier hinten
steht jetzt nur noch das auf itunes und
so erhältlich ist allerdings stand in
den kommentaren auch einfach von latif
schokolade geklaut das heißt ich kopiere
das ganze jetzt mal latif schokolade ist
ein lied mit ava imani es hat 260
millionen aufrufe ist ein jahr alt es
hat 260 millionen aufrufe wie so kenne
ich das denn nicht
also man muss sagen der beat ist genauso
wie bei apa/red hier nochmal der beginn
von apa red
und jetzt schauen wir uns einmal hier
ganz kurz team geht vom latif schokolade
an
also das ist wirklich exakt leicht die
das ding drin
das ist komplett kopiert ja das ist
schon sehr sehr stark daran orientiert
ab hier ist die huk von bülow also ich
will jetzt einfach mal kurz of play
ja das war die hoch von pille und jetzt
mal die hoch von schokolade
[Musik]
andere
es geht also die hochgesetzt nicht so
krass ähnlich aber man sieht dass er
sich daran orientiert hat ich muss
allerdings trotzdem sagen dass wenn hier
beispielsweise dieser ebene ist alles
darunter hals orientiert dann etwas
inspiriert dann etwas und das hier
drüber ist okay das ist wirklich
komplett kopiert dann trifft er genau
die mitte der tranquilo von upgrade ist
eine mischung aus raff camora komplett
daran orientiert was deutschrap angeht
und latif schokolade das hat er sich so
als vorlage genommen es ist so wie wenn
ihr euch einen cheeseburger macht anhand
eines rezeptes in dem kochbuch und dann
klatscht allerdings noch becken drauf
und das einzige was euren kies burger
von nimmt dem anderen cheeseburger aus
dem rezept unterscheidet ist quasi der
bacon und das ist in dem fall dass es ab
von kabarettist und nicht von lat ist in
kombination mit der kamera
das war es jetzt allerdings auch von
meiner reaction hier auf den song wenn
euch ein video hier gefallen hat las
gerne mal ein like da ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen apa red ich finde den song
mega ich hoffe du entwickelt sich weiter
in die richtung und versucht sich noch
ein bisschen eigen zu machen also nicht
so krass an anderen sachen zu
orientieren sondern vielleicht jetzt
einen komplett eigenen stil zu
entwickeln für mich ist bilder auf jeden
fall schon so der sorgen der youtuber
sorgen des januars mehr oder weniger als
er ist schon relativ gut gelungen
deswegen abo respekt
[Musik]